[MUSIC PLAYING]
VINIT MODI: We started exploring
how to improve the Android
camera experience and
discovered that over 70%
of all camera usage occurs
on developer-made apps
versus the native camera.
So we heard from many
developers that they'd
like to make Android
camera development easy,
like managing the
Android device variation.
And they're craving
access to the latest
features like night mode.
So we built CameraX, a
Jetpack support library
that makes development
incredibly simple
and enables new features
with just two lines of code.
CameraX just works
across many devices.
You don't have to do
device-specific testing.
Google takes care of
that on your behalf.
We made a significant investment
into an automated camera test
lab that does
basic functionality
testing like rotation,
orientation, taking
a picture, et cetera.
This significantly
reduces the test burden
the developers have today.
LOUIS CHEN: One of the
features that we really
like in CameraX is the
extension capability.
So users will be able to take
very high dynamically ranged
images.
The [INAUDIBLE] is very highly
wanted by our user base.
So we are creating a series of
different [INAUDIBLE] effects
that can be also implemented on
top of the CameraX extension.
TAO LI: We have been
paying close attention
to new technologies and APIs.
CameraX has been a bridge
through in camera API for us.
RUI MA: It has reduced our
core camera code by 2/3,
and greatly improved the
efficiency of new product
developments.
VINIT MODI: CameraX is
backwards-compatible to Android
L or API 21, and works
seamlessly with Kotlin.
CameraX enables developers
to get the same features
as the native camera.
We've been working
with many developers
from around the world,
and we're excited for you
to try out this new API.
[MUSIC PLAYING]